les talibans sont donc à bollée souhaite
un transfert pacifique du pouvoir dans
les prochains jours le président achraf
gagné a même quitté le pays cet après
midi est de son côté l'elysée précise
que la france met tout en oeuvre pour
assurer la sécurité des français encore
sûr emmanuel macron elle s'exprime sur
le sujet demain à 20 heures
la situation également à compliquer au
liban après la pénurie de biens de
première nécessité un camion citerne a
explosé hier soir un bilan 28 morts et
le pays craint aujourd'hui un black out
général des hôpitaux ont d'ores et déjà
très bas et redoutent les puits second
de leurs générateurs dans les 48 heures
et donc l'arrêt total de leur activité
[Musique]
et plus de 700 morts et d
des blessés c'est le dernier bilan
provisoire du séisme qui a frappé haïti
ce matin est les habitants et les forces
de sécurité toujours à la recherche de
st alors que la crise politique et
sanitaire à frappe le pays depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
si vous nous rejoignez sur rt france
kaboul capitale de l'afghanistan sur le
point de tomber aux mains des talibans
les insurgés sont entrés dans la ville
et certains de leurs représentants sont
actuellement en train de négocier avec
le pouvoir en place est les insurgés qui
souhaite d'ailleurs à un transfert
pacifique du pouvoir dans les jours à
venir à des négociations qui se feront
sans le président afghan ashraf ghani
qui a quitté le pays cet après midi elle
leur prise de pouvoir total ne sera donc
plus qu'une question de temps mais les
autorités se veulent rassurantes les
détails de françois disque et nietzsche
embouteillages monstres dans les rues de
la capitale afghane des habitants
tentent de fuir quelques minutes après
l'annnonce de l'arrivée des talibans aux
portes de kaboul d'autres font la queue
devant les banques pour retirer leur
argent
je suis ici pour retirer mon salaire le
gouvernement ne résout pas nos problèmes
je suis ici depuis six heures personne
ne fait attention à nous beaucoup de
gens se sont rassemblés ici ils veulent
retirer leur argent personne ne nous
écoute
une cacophonie qui contraste avec le
calme régnant dans cet autre quartier et
des habitants plongée dans l'inconnu
réclamant juste la paix
pour l'instant tout va bien les gens
sont bien avec eux ils disent que tout
le monde peut aller à l'école les filles
et les garçons la vie est normale mais
dans le futur on ne sait pas c'est à peu
près ça récemment la vie est devenue
difficile pour les gens les gens
s'inquiètent de la façon dont les
talibans nous traiter avant mais
maintenant c'est un peu différent nous
voulons juste la paix
peace les talibans assurent vouloir
reprendre le contrôle du pouvoir dans
les jours à venir par un transfert
pacifique
par l'intermédiaire d'un de leurs
porte-parole il repousse les craintes
d'un retour du pays dans l'époque de la
première domination talibane avec une
application très stricte des règles
islamiques
nous voulons un gouvernement islamique
inclusif ce qui signifie que l'ensemble
des afghans seront représentés dans ce
gouvernement nous voulons travailler
avec tous les afghans nous voulons
ouvrir un nouveau chapitre de paix de
tolérance avec une coexistence pacifique
et unité nationale pour le pays le
peuple afghan il n'y a aucun risque pour
les diplomates les organisations
humanitaires personnes ils devraient
tous continuer à travailler comme ils
l'ont fait jusqu'à présent aucun mal ne
leur sera fait il devrait rester du côté
du gouvernement afghan on essaie tant
bien que mal de rassurer les habitants
de la capitale
les gens ne doivent pas être inquiet la
ville est sécurisé quiconque provoque
des troubles dans la ville devra faire
face à une confrontation sérieuse
la sécurité de la ville est garanti il
ne sera pas attaqué l'accord pour la
grande ville de kaboul et que le pouvoir
sera transférée pacifiquement à une
administration intérimaire
le président afghan ashraf ghani à lui
déjà quitté le pays laissant aux
talibans la voie libre au palais
présidentiel
et selon un choix bas najafi zada
journalistes à kaboul les talibans
auraient changé la transition vers un
pouvoir taliban pourrait même être bien
vécu par la population sur place écoutez
le
d'après les informations que nous avons
il semble que les talibans aient changé
qu'il n'est pas le même comportement
qu'ils avaient 20 ans auparavant
leur expérience leur a appris qu'avec un
visage agressif il est impossible de
gouverner un pays de gouverner le peuple
afghan
et d'après les gens qui vivent
actuellement sous le contrôle des
talibans dans les provinces de
l'afghanistan avec qui j'ai parlé ils
sont content du comportement des
talibans et disent que les talibans ne
pose pas de problème aux gens qui
laissent les étudiants allaient à
l'école qui laisse les gens aller au
travail
les villes est récemment tombée aux
mains des talibans retourne maintenant à
leur fonctionnement normal je pense
qu'après la transition nous reprendrons
notre travail normal bien sûr il y aura
des restrictions des limites imposées au
peuple afghan par les talibans j'espère
que ces restrictions ne seront pas trop
lourde insupportable pour le peuple
c'est un désastre pour l'armée afghane
en déroute pourtant financé pendant 20
ans ont par les états unis washington
qui est désormais pointé du doigt pour
ses erreurs stratégiques et mardi si
l'on en croit l'administration
américaine l'afghanistan a les moyens de
se battre qu'il ne leur manquerait que
la volonté ils doivent se battre pour
eux mêmes se battre pour leur nation
les forces afghanes ont l'équipement les
effectifs et l'entraînement nécessaire
pour riposter
elles ont ce dont elles ont besoin ce
qu'ils doivent déterminer s'ils ont la
volonté politique et la capacité de
s'unir pour riposter alors il est vrai
que les forces de sécurité afghanes ont
été largement financée par l'oncle sam
plus de 80 milliards de dollars en deux
décennies rien que depuis le début de
l'année l'otan a fait don à l'armée
afghane de plus de 70 millions de
dollars en équipements mais si malgré ce
soutien la défense du pays est
aujourd'hui totalement submergé c'est
que les états unis sont partis en
laissant une administration afghane
totalement défaillante la police afghane
qui est militarisée et combat depuis des
bases de première ligne n'a pas été
payés depuis des mois par le ministère
de l'intérieur il en va de même pour le
ministère de la défense dans de
nombreuses régions les soldats et les
policiers ne reçoivent pas suffisamment
de nourriture d'eau de munitions ou
d'armes les lignes d'approvisionnement
sont pillées et l'une des raisons de
cette situation c'est le manque de
vision stratégique à long terme des
responsables américains chargés de
mettre sur pied la défense du pays
depuis le tout début
les efforts de l'armée américaine pour
conseiller encadrer les forces afghanes
ont été traités comme un jeu de hasard
informel ponctuelles et sans stratégie
nous n'avons pas réussi à construire les
forces afghanes en tant qu'institution
nous avons échoué à mettre en place
l'infrastructure nécessaire qui traite
efficacement de l'éducation militaires
de la formation des systèmes de
rémunération de l'avancement
professionnel du personnel de la
responsabilité toutes ces choses qui
font une force de sécurité
professionnelle
selon le guardian washington aurait par
ailleurs tardé à financer la défense
afghane après l'invasion du pays ce qui
a laissé le temps aux talibans de
rassembler leurs forces si nous avions
commencé avec les forces de sécurité
nationales afghanes déjouant 2002
lorsque les taliban étaient faibles et
désorganisé les choses auraient
peut-être été différente au lieu de cela
nous sommes allés en irak et l'on
pourrait trouver à redire sur la
formation des troupes afghanes parfois
délaissés au profit du recrutement
d'effectifs toujours plus importants mal
dirigés et sur lesquels le gouvernement
central a toujours eu du mal à exercer
son autorité un gouvernement central de
plus notoirement corrompu et coupé de sa
population résultat après le départ des
troupes américaine les soldats afghans
ont été livrés à eux-mêmes craignant
pour leur vie et celle de leur famille
en cas de représailles des talibans ils
ont ainsi été nombreux à déserter en
abandonnant au passage le précieux
matériel américain qui vient s'ajouter à
l'arsenal des insurgés c'est sans doute
ce qui explique la progression
fulgurante des forces talibanes au cours
des derniers jours et qui a même pris de
court les experts militaires de
l'administration américaine écouter la
boule ne se trouve pas actuellement dans
un contexte de menace imminente
au final après deux décennies de guerre
plus de 160 mille morts et 1000
milliards de dollars dépensés par les
états unis l'afghanistan retomber aux
mains des talibans comme en 1996 l'année
de leur première conquête du pays des
talibans que les états unis avaient
contribué armés et formés quelques
années plus tôt afin de combattre les
russes présents dans le pays entre 1979
et 1989 comme quoi qui sème le vent vous
connaissez l'expression et washington
qui maintient que les objectifs de la
guerre en afghanistan était atteint
écouter justement l analyse de régis le
sommier grand reporter qui vient de
passer trois semaines en afghanistan
selon lui s'il arrivait au pouvoir des
talibans plonge le pays dans l'inconnu
écoutez
la finalité de la présence américaine
n'a jamais été clair au départ la
mission c'était d'éradiquer al qaïda est
de faire en sorte que des groupes ne
puisse pas se servir de l'afghanistan
comme un sanctuaire on préparait des
opérations à l'étranger en réalité
aujourd'hui il ya une grande inconnue là
dessus puisque les talibans n'ont pour
le moment pas officiellement
coupé le coupé les ponts avec al qaïda
il trie ils prétendent moi je suis allé
les rencontrer et j'aurais pose
évidemment la question de savoir s'il
laisserait dans leur nous dans le
nouveau régime qui sont en train de
mettre en place ce qui laisserait les
groupes comme al qaïda se déployer ils
ne répondent pas il botte il botte en
touche il explique que par contre leur
vision de l'islam va s'imposer ils vont
comment imposer la charia là aussi c'est
pareil on ne sait pas exactement ce que
ça recoupe est-ce que ça recoupe
de revenir au traitement qui avait été
aux exécutions publiques au plan des
longs aux mains coupées pour les voleurs
est ce que ce type de comportement
barbare et archaïque vont avoir à
nouveau pignon sur rue en afghanistan et
puis toute la question c'est la moitié
des afghans c'est à dire les afghanes
qu'est-ce que vas tu que vont devenir
les afghanes elle qui avait obtenu
certains droits pendant ses vingt ans de
présence américaine la toutoute cette
question là elle elle est sous la tente
on ne sait pas exactement quelle sera la
politique des talibans et puis il faut
aussi regarder ce qu'ils feront avec
l'étranger quelle position il choisira
ils choisiront vont-ils avoir une
représentation à l'onu vont ils ou
est-ce que ça va être un pays interdit
un pays fermé
tout ça est pour le moment une grande
inconnue et réactions côté russe à cette
situation en afghanistan la russie qui
souhaite à la tenue d'une réunion
d'urgence au conseil de sécurité de
l'onu moscou qui ne veut pas évacuer son
ambassade à kaboul elle les précisions
de notre correspondante à moscou ferait
d'hoffmann la russie ses partenaires
oeuvre pour la tenue d'une réunion
d'urgence du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu concernant la situation d'un
organiste ans à communiquer l'envoyé
spécial russe pour l'afghanistan amir
kaboul of hell assuré que cette réunion
devait se passer bientôt selon kamolov
la russie à la différence des états unis
ne prépare pas l'évocation de son
ambassade en afghanistan la mission
diplomatique travail de façon sereine et
suit de près l'évolution de la situation
dans le pays les talibans avaient
auparavant garantit la sécurité aurait
sorti son russe ainsi qu'aux autres
missions diplomatiques pour la porte
parole du ministère russe des affaires
étrangères marie à dakar au vin en
afghanistan s'affrontent en ce moment de
force créée par les états unis je vous
propose d'écouter cela peut surprendre
mais c'est en fait en afghanistan se
déroule un affrontement entre des forces
qui sont toutes deux le fruit du
processus réflexif des états unis le
monde suit avec horreur le résultat
d'une énième expérience historique de
washington
les talibans ont lancé leurs enfants
aussi vent mais elle faveur du retrait
final des troupes américaines qui doit
être achevé d'ici le 31 août face à
cette offensive jobs hayden a décidé le
14 août de portet à 5000 soldats le
déploiement militaire à kaboul pour
sécuriser l'évacuation de civils tout en
défendant sa décision de mettre fin à 20
ans de guerre en afghanistan
mais la france y elle aussi réagi à
l'avancée des talibans et qui comme
d'autres pays des places elle son
ambassade à l'aéroport de kaboul l
elysée s ur mettre tout en oeuvre pour
évacuer les français sur place et
emmanuel macron va s'exprimer sur le
sujet demain soir écoutez justement ces
quelques réactions de politiques
français à la situation en afghanistan
j'ai applaudi la défaite us au vietnam
je suis écoeuré par la déroute en
afghanistan il est temps de réfléchir
avant de s'engager dans des guerres sans
issue car si la guerre ne règle rien la
défaite change tout on ferait bien d'y
penser au mali quand je lis les
commentaires insensible à ce que vivent
ces populations civiles désarmées qui
fuient la barbarie des talibans géante
faut-il rappeler ce que furent les
routes de l'exode face au nazisme et que
nous fûmes sauvé par l'héroïsme
d'étrangers pendant que ces technocrates
débattent du sexe des anges et profère
leurs menaces dérisoire l'islamisme
avance se renforce et va installer un
califat en afghanistan mettant nos
peuples et la sécurité du monde en grave
danger comme toujours l'union européenne
est en dessous de tout la reconquête de
l'afghanistan par les talibans est une
tragédie pour ce pays et une nouvelle
menace pour la paix du monde par
faiblesse coupable l'occident perd une
bataille essentielle dans la guerre
contre l'islamisme
situation à critique également un ro
liban qui s'enfonce chaque jour un petit
peu plus dans la crise
le pays vit en ce moment une grave
pénurie
de biens de première nécessité dont du
carburant la situation a empiré s'est
tenue après l'explosion d'un
camion-citerne tuant 28 personnes et les
hôpitaux sur place craignent même de ne
plus pouvoir fonctionner à cause du
manque d'électricité
avaya soubelet
une armée mobilisée qui prêtent main
forte à la population depuis plusieurs
jours les libanais bloquent les routes
du pays pour protester contre
l'augmentation des prix du carburant
prise d'assaut ce samedi les soldats
distribuent les stocks gratuitement aux
automobilistes
chaque jour je dois aller me faire une
piqûre à l'hôpital j'ai la sclérose en
plaques l'armée m'a fait le plan est
maintenant c'est bon ils m'ont aussi
remplir un bidon d'essence
objectif des militaires faire respecter
l'accord conclu entre la banque du liban
et le ministère de l'énergie
les stations essence tenue de vider
leurs stocks au prix subventionné ont
décidé de fermer leurs portes pour
profiter d'une future flambée des prix
ce jeudi la banque du liban à cesser de
subventionner l'importation de carburant
qui prédit une hausse de 300% des prix
de l'essence et du mazout une décision
dont se défend le gouverneur de la
banque ce samedi riad salamé assume sa
position et pointe du doigt
l'irresponsabilité de l'état
lorsque les réserves obligatoires à la
banque du liban atteignent une ligne
rouge la banque du liban n'a d'autre
choix que d'arrêter le financement des
importations de carburant tous les
responsables libanais étaient au courant
de la décision de lever les subventions
à commencer par la présidence de la
république en passant par le
gouvernement sans oublier le conseil
supérieur de défense qu'ils aillent au
parlement et qu'ils votent la loi au
lieu de jouer la comédie le gouvernement
en effet la possibilité d'adopter une
loi qui autorise la banque du liban à
puiser dans les réserves du pays
le gouverneur de la banque appelle
également à la formation d'un
gouvernement
afin de pouvoir entamer les réformes qui
pourront venir à bout d'une crise
économique qui s'enlise la flambée du
carburant constitue une inquiétude
supplémentaire pour les hôpitaux et les
commerçants qui doivent alimenter leurs
générateurs électriques et ne peuvent
plus se fournir en diesel
nous sommes les seuls qui restent les
grandes boulangeries ont cessé
d'apporter du pain dans le quartier donc
la pression est sur nous en raison de
notre petite production nous n'avons
reçu que 36 tonnes de farine
subventionnée
donc si la crise persiste nous ne
tiendrons pas plus d'une semaine et je
ne sais pas quoi faire je travaille avec
tout ce que j'ai je ne cache pas un
grain de farine
alors que la livre libanaise connaît une
dévaluation sans précédent de 90 % de sa
valeur
les libanais dépense désormais cinq fois
leur salaire pour l'achat des denrées
alimentaires
à cette détresse économique s'ajoute un
manque de médicaments et de nombreux
produits de première nécessité dans un
contexte de crise sanitaire qui voit une
résurgence des cas de kovy 19
et pour jamal au wakim professeur
d'histoire contemporaine et de relations
internationales à l'université libanaise
à ces pénuries sont dus à l'inaction des
dirigeants et à la crise économique
la situation économique s'aggrave il la
situation sociale
va s'aggraver
en même temps la classe politique n'a
pas de solution la nomination de najib
mikati ne va pas résoudre le problème
parce que
c'est un problème
structurel
dans le pays
de l'économie de ce pays qui a changé
depuis 30 ans à une économie de services
de banquière
rentière alors on n'a pas de production
locale
90% de ce qu'on consomme en la peau
on éthiciens deuxième séisme au moins de
24 heures a frappé le pays tôt ce matin
et le bilan encore provisoire est très
lourd au moins elle 724 morts et 2800
blessés et les sauveteurs cherchent
encore des survivants en drame alors que
le pays traverse actuellement une crise
sanitaire et politique sans précédent
traces d'aia
une secousse qui rappelle le cauchemar
du séisme de 2010 scènes d'apocalypse
sur l'île au lendemain du tremblement de
terre en haïti les secours accompagnés
de la population continue à chercher les
disparus ici dans la commune des cayes
c'est le corps de la petite esther sept
ans qui vient d'être retrouvé sans vie
cette femme sortie de son commerce quand
c'est arrivé elle est toujours
stupéfaite
j'ai senti le mouvement pendant que je
marchais j'ai regardé devant moi et j'ai
senti que la terre bouge et j'ai vu que
tout tomber quand je suis arrivée chez
moi j'ai réalisé l'étendue des dégâts je
n'ai jamais rien vu de pareil
dans toute la ville les dégâts sont
considérables
cet avion privé a été loué pour
transporter les blessés toujours plus
nombreux et un glissement de terrain a
bloqué la route retardant l'arrivée des
secours qui réclament du soutien
il y a eu de répliques après le
tremblement de terre il y a beaucoup de
blessés il faut beaucoup dead il y a
beaucoup de morts le sénateur de la
commune des cayes est aussi blessé il
faut beaucoup de médicaments l'aide des
autorités l'aide de la communauté
internationale des ong de toutes les
institutions qui sont ici
côté politique d'urgence et à
l'évaluation de la situation et à
l'organisation pour acheminer une aide
plus structuré que pendant le séisme de
nous appelons à beaucoup de solidarité
mais une solidarité très structurée
nous mettons en place une task force
pour coordonner l'aide
pour que ce qui s'est passé le 12
janvier 2010 ne se reproduise plus
le premier ministre a déclaré un état
d'urgence d'un mois pour l'ensemble du
pays une catastrophe qui risque de
plonger encore un peu plus ces pays dans
l'instabilité
le 7 juillet dernier le président
jouvenel moïse était assassiné à son
domicile
quarante quatre suspects dont 12
policiers haïtiens ont déjà été arrêtés
mais il ya quelques jours le juge champ
là tu charges et de l'enquète a renoncé
au dossier une décision plus surprenante
car depuis plusieurs années le pays est
gangrénée par la présence de gangs armés
qui ont nettement profité du contexte de
contestation politique et sociale dans
lequel se trouvent les pays depuis plus
de deux ans
et on disait en situation donc critique
en haïti après ça séisme on en parle
justement avec est le chef de la
communication de nice f en haïti ndiaga
sec
bonsoir ndiaga sec merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur arte france alors tout
d'abord où en sont les recherches
actuellement en haîti
poursuivre on sait qu'on a plus de 700
personnes qui ont perdu la vie et deux
autres
blessés mais les richesses de pouce ppi
et dans les jours qui vont suivre nous
allons bien sûr demander publie d'autres
corps et d'autres personnes blessées il
sortirait un peu de là où ils sont pour
pouvoir accéder aux soins d'aller clan
de pitot alors vous nous dites que les
recherches se poursuivent actuellement
et quels sont justement les moyens mis
en place pour dans le cadre de de ses
recherches
les moyens sont souvent des moyens
communautaire vous savez c'est dans des
zones assez reculée et ici à l'est de
port-au-prince vers le sud par exemple a
été toujours très difficile vu la
violence des gangs
et vu la l'insécurité qui prévalaient il
est vrai que on a pu essayer de passer
par marc qui sort pour aller dans le sud
mais pour la plupart il fallait prendre
l'hélicoptère pour pouvoir y aller ou
prendre des détours assez loin pour pour
y arriver donc c'est les communautés qui
amène d'abord les tout premiers soirs où
qui amène les toutes premières aides
légère travaille avec des jeunes qu'on
appelle lui reporter et ce sont des
jeunes qui sont dans les communautés et
ces jeunes là ont pu se déployer très
rapidement pour aider leur communauté
comme limite impôts s'ils avaient des
staffs sur le terrain parce que nous
avons un bureau à les cayes qui couvre
le sud
nos stars étaient déjà sur le terrain
dès les premières heures
de pouvoir aider les communautés à mener
alors haïti fait face un également comme
beaucoup de pays du monde à la pandémie
de convives 19 est ce que le système de
santé en haïti va pouvoir gérer les
victimes de ce séisme est ce que
justement ce système de santé va pouvoir
prendre en charge tout le monde les
malades habituels les malades du co lead
et les victimes de de ce séisme
oui dès hier nous avons envoyé un camion
qui est plein de médicaments plein dans
le tram médicaux pour les trois grands
hôpitaux de la zone et ses médicaments
et c'est un tram et du corps pour servir
contre 1000 personnes pendant trois mois
parce que pour nous l'essentiel c'était
d'aller très vite en réponse aux blessés
donc renforcer le système sanitaire qui
était déjà en place avec la vaccination
de covile 19 qu'on a commencé depuis la
troisième semaine du mois de juillet
l'unicef avait déjà mis en place des
frigos solaire tour on a regardé les
vaccins moderna qu'on avait reçu et la
vaccination avait bel et bien commencée
cependant ce séisme va être un coup de
frein à ce vaccin du que tout le monde
sera focalisée sur la réponse urgente a
amené à
fait déplacée à ses blessés en effet
aussi parfois de les évacuer vers port
au prince ce qui est fort difficile
parfois vu que certaines grandes routes
moi même ont été coupées par des
éboulements et cetera donc voilà c'est
ce ne sera pas très très simple mais la
pluie est déjà sur place les grâces de
plus tôt ont reçu la plupart des cas
merci beaucoup nvidia c'est que diagast
pardon d'avoir été avec nous ce soir sur
rtl france rappelle que vous êtes chef
de la communication à d'unicef en haïti
merci beaucoup
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous d'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité dans un peu plus de trente
minutes reste avec nous sur arte france
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe islamisme radical de
la saur c'est l'élite des renseignements
généraux de la police française c'était
après les attentats du 11 septembre et
quand on vient vous voir et qu'on vous
dit écoutez vous avez de la première
femme qui allait rentrer dans ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que voilà c'est fini pour moi